the next day I woke up with just like a
different fire man it's like so
different the feeling after you serve
people man how can I Market my podcast I
want to know if you can maybe give me
some feedback so far on the channel I'm
super pumped man like this is the
beginning of an amazing journey how do I
cross that line how do I close my
clients what you're about to watch is a
special private training session for
people who bought a copy of my book
built the surf enjoy
laughs
hello everybody super excited to be here
it's been an insane insane insane day
and now we're here insiders and get to
help hopefully uh teach learn Inspire
support and I made this group
um with Zan's help on Sandra's help to
just be an extra resource and and
supportive place you guys bought the
book I don't want it just to sit on the
Shelf I want it to be something valuable
and we do uh whatever's on your mind
coaching helping you got a question
raise your hand and then we'll dive in
and do as many as we can wealth mindset
in the house now what do we got man how
can I help uh great to see you guys
happy to be here so uh Hey a couple of
quick things number one thank you for
this whole for the book for the
challenge I had a conversation with Evan
and a lot of the members in the team
last week about how as a result of the
book I remember you know I had the
pleasure of being on the hot seat
uh and you know actually for some input
I wasn't sure how to launch my channel
what type of uh content to create and
then you gave me advice and and
I didn't know how to use the advice but
like I always say the one thing I
learned about Evan is just take the
action you know so I don't know that I
started to implement the advice that you
gave me yet what I have it into my
channel but I took the chat uh you know
action and started the channel I
committed to posting uh a video every
day let's go dude let's go I've been
posting a video every day after this I'm
gonna record a video and post it today
because and I don't I don't you know we
talked about yesterday uh and um or
Monday yesterday Tuesday I don't know
what day it is
um in the momentum success program about
the the mindset tip from uh momentum the
book right chapter one and so the Mayan
is focusing on the why and not the how
so you know I I'm I'm comfortable and
you know not knowing what I'm doing not
knowing what I'm going to post but every
day something happens I just I believe
great ideas flow through me and
Something's Gonna Come Something's Gonna
click and I'm gonna I'm gonna put up
content so thank you you know thank you
for all of that so with that I want to
know if you can maybe give me some
feedback so far on the channel maybe my
uh I know I know Chris told me last week
about thumbnails but if you wanted to to
dissect what I have and give me some
constructive criticism I'm here for
whatever you got for me I'm here for it
got it okay so this is the channel right
here yes okay so
I mean wealth mindset Academy just has a
name is decent but I I honestly think
then your personal brand is going to be
a lot better people connect with people
much more than just text on a screen so
making it the the you know Jose if you
want to support wealth mindset in there
cool but like make it you your face
your name
we need to we need a banner at the top
the bigger channels will have some kind
of banner if you go to the top 10
Channel
you know so there's a banner right like
that's watching top 10 with bolivation
because I love it so me and Brandon
burchard but like what what are you some
kind of banner at the top that that
talks to what you're all about
uh the videos themselves
we want to have a a title that reflects
the content so I wouldn't put wealth
mindset Academy in the text of any of
the thumbnails heard
make it about what I'm gonna get from
this message
and then your face should be a lot
bigger who is this guy this could be
anybody it's like some guy in a suit
so we need to see your face on all these
videos and then maybe a last challenge
here is to make them longer
10 minutes plus every video
copy uh so none of these like three
minute
two minute kind of videos go longer uh
and like episode number and stuff
doesn't matter
good mindset Monday doesn't matter
what am I going to learn in this video
what are you gonna teach me what are you
talking about that's gonna make me start
to question some of my mindsets so
that's a good that's a good starting
point Thank you thank you very much
awesome Jose all right let's get uh
Carlos in the house hey Carlos what do
we got man hey uh this is my third call
and um man I'm just so happy to be on
this call on the energy and and to even
be chatting with you man this is crazy
but I want to let you know uh speaking
about the hot seat Jose was saying I was
put in the hot seat last week I uh
um I didn't take that step on my social
media and um and it was definitely a
mind uh mindset block which Ronald
brought out to me and and uh I made the
Jump Man and and the fear wasn't as bad
as I thought it was going to be so
um I I I I posted on my Instagram
Channel that I am going into coaching
that I'm making a new journey into
coaching I'm looking for uh you know I'm
giving I I want to help um people with
their child trauma and as well as uh
um help men be better fathers and
husbands
um and I'm looking for some you know two
free clients that I can get free
coaching to for for the next month uh
just to get my feet wet and things like
that and man lo and behold man I got
three people that reached out to me and
what's crazy is that I was so scared to
be to put it on my on my IG account on
my personal one I had all my friends and
family I was going to create a whole new
one but everyone in this group was like
put it on that one put it on that one
and I did and it was people it was
friends and family that reached out to
me that really needed help one guy
couldn't even Market on my account he's
like can we talk right now so I was very
surprised man and the response I got
when I spoke to them just like the next
day I woke up after helping this
longtime friend of mine out you know
just speaking to him and everything the
next day I woke up with just like a
different fire man it's like so
different the feeling after you serve
people man it's it's way different so my
question is that I have the three people
that I'm giving this free coaching to
right now
two of them are long time friends from
when I was younger right
and I know I'm gonna have to get to the
point where I'm going to have to drop
them about you know I I'm I'm going to
want to do this and it's going to cost
however so much per month uh given my
pricing and things like that
I don't have and I want to have this
sales technique in the marketing down
but I don't know how to drop it to them
and bring it to that is there kind of a
script or can you lead me in a way so
that I can uh close them you know what I
mean because for me it's I think that's
that's my next Roblox how do I close
these guys I knew them since I was
younger and we have a friend a friend
militia I feel like I'm talking to them
as a friend right now I'm helping a lot
and then how and how am I going to cross
that line to make it hey it's it's it's
actually a business this is something I
I plan to do how do I cross that line
how do I how do I close my clients yeah
cool well first off dude congrats it's
amazing that's amazing that you did it
and you got the push and uh Zane's
pretty good at putting people on the
spot so that's uh good that you you said
yes and you know use the group to help
you actually start creating the
momentums I'm super pumped man like this
is the beginning of an amazing journey
um I wouldn't stress out about a perfect
script especially for your friends
because your friends are not going to be
how you ultimately scale you know like
you're going to have a hundred clients
most of them will not be friends that
you've known for 20 years or whatever
so the way through it is if you're
worried about
being
too much of a hard sell person right
then you just it's just an invitation so
I remember doing this with um the first
person I was coaching how to be a coach
and like how do you build a full-time
business off of being a coach and she
would do free sessions and then at the
end of the free session she'd follow up
there's some homework there's some like
what do you do you know like what like
Zan gave you homework hey you have to go
do this you have to make an IG and tell
people about it so a great coach would
give some kind of homework afterwards so
you're giving them homework
live on the session then you send a DM
on Instagram
the next day and you follow up you say
hey two quick things one checking in the
awesome awesome IG live yesterday thank
you for coming on sharing your story
I'm checking in to see how you're doing
on the thing that we talked about and
also if you want I do this as a business
if you and we do this once a month or
once a week not live on Instagram but to
actually help you gain momentum around
the challenge that you're trying to
solve now that would be like a generic
message if it's your friend that you've
known for 20 years you can customize it
to be a lot more you know personal or
maybe you don't charge your friends I
mean it's up to you I'm less worried
about your friends and more about the
people who discover you because that's
how you're going to build the business
but it's assigning stuff like a template
don't I wouldn't worry about a perfect
script because in the scripting it feels
like a script and it's less from the
heart and then you don't end up
converting people as much but it's offer
them give them some kind of assignment
some kind of homework like what do they
have to do as a next step and then the
next day you reach out and you ask them
how they're doing on that step and
letting them know that you have packages
available they want ongoing support from
you
um okay okay and I could just you it
doesn't have to be on my on friends as
well too I mean for whoever because I
know one one of the one of my clients is
it's not you know I wouldn't consider
him a friend friend it's just something
that's an acquaintance on IG but I get
what you're saying there
um is is is is dropping them the price
after the fact and I did give these guys
a homework assignment as well too after
we got off the call so that we have
something to discuss on the next one so
uh that makes sense that makes sense I
guess uh I'll have to think of that
um
that of what I'm actually going to say
it's not stressing about the perfect
words like if if I wanted to get Jose as
a client or like like look at what just
happened with Jose and he's looking
we're looking at the website if this was
an Instagram live and it's like hey you
know help me with my my YouTube channel
and we pull it up and the next homework
I gave him homework what was the
homework Jose change the titles of your
videos make them longer go 10 minutes
plus you know put your face on on each
thumbnail change the name of the thing
to actually have Jose Gonzalez you know
in the top like I gave him a whole bunch
of homework that he's supposed to do if
I was trying to and I don't even think
of it as like close him you can because
like if I wanted if I wanted to invite
him to
be a client right then I'm going to
coach then I would follow up the next
day and say hey hey Jose dude thank you
for showing up yesterday was awesome and
and being you know in front of everybody
and being willing to take feedback
two things just wanted to check in on
you see how you're doing how's the
channel coming along did you did you do
the 10 minute video
um and also if you wanted to continue
doing more sessions with me
where it's private not always on
Instagram but I do have a program where
it's either once a week talking to me or
once a month talking to me to help you
actually create that YouTube channel
that you're trying to create no pressure
either way just letting you know and
sending you a bunch of love
you know it's like it's an invitation
it's not a perfect script
ion based off of what
what we talked about right which is all
around his YouTube channel you're going
to talk about
the childhood trauma or being a better
dad and then give them some kind of
homework they're gonna have to write a
letter to themselves or have a
conversation with their wife or talk to
their son or whatever right
um and then if you they may they may say
no they may they may not respond they
may uh ask how much they may not be
ready or they may say yeah like how do
we get started
I care less about the ongoing follow-up
like I'm not if Jose said no or not
right now or I'm not ready or he ignored
the message or whatever like if you have
enough people coming in then it doesn't
matter if one person says yes or no I'm
not gonna follow up with Jose every week
and say hey Jose you ready now hey Jose
you ready now hey Jose you ready now
right I would just keep creating content
I'll just keep making my show because
Jose is going to watch the show and
people like Jose will continue to watch
my content and my show and keep opening
up in the door and you open up doors and
see who walks through as opposed to like
pushing people or pulling them with a
lot of stress you know through the door
gotcha that sounds awesome within that
like you back the mindset like you have
to do the work to at least give them the
invitation because that's where a lot of
people struggles like they do the free
coaching
but then they never follow up at all
they never check in they never the
person like Jose may not even know that
you have this thing as a service
right so don't just assume they're gonna
say no and then you never give them the
invitation or that they they need to ask
you to you know become their coach
so it doesn't have to be a hard sell but
you do have to do your part to give them
that invitation to join you gotcha
gotcha awesome man makes a lot of sense
also I know that you know with coaching
it's not really regulated but my another
thing that's been popping around in my
head is that what about if they ask for
a cert or do you have any certifications
I I really want to get assert like I I
want to advance my knowledge as being a
coach uh do you have any recommendations
for courses or search that I can
possibly look at you have to understand
like why are you doing it so if you're
doing it just to learn cool like great
like as as much learning as you can get
the better whether it's movement makers
whether it's some other coaching program
cool like the more you can learn the
better
uh the most important thing is that
you're not
you don't need to kind of hide behind it
to give you validation
like nobody asked me
what my YouTube certification is nobody
asked me what my entrepreneur
certification is nobody asked me what my
University education is nobody cares
that I went to University of Toronto and
I got my you know bachelor of Commerce
or if I had a PhD or not like nobody
cares
um a lot of times
I think if you're doing it for the
learning it's great most people are
doing it just for the crutch
like you feel like oh I can't do it
until I've been certified and I have
this piece of paper like the piece of
paper isn't the thing the knowledge is
the thing gotcha makes sense in some
Fields it matters like if you're gonna
be my surgeon you better have gone and
gotten your degree I hope and not just I
don't know I kind of feel my way through
it
right but for most of the things it
doesn't matter and nobody asks and so
it's you knowing that you bring value
and that you can help and only help with
the things that you know how to help you
know like you're asking me questions
about coaching and selling and we've
done that so I can I can answer it Jose
is asking me about his YouTube channel
like I've done that I can help if you're
coming on and asking me about
most other things I have no idea yeah
like how to how to grow carrots I don't
know
I know how to grow carrots so I'm not
going to pretend like I know so it's
okay to not have an answer like if some
like you ask me about captions I said I
don't edit my videos I don't know but we
I we had a guy on today he recommended
captions so
uh don't feel like you have to have an
answer to every question you answer what
you know and you know or not like you
know a lot and that can help people and
the certification is not going to help
you
sell more or have be have more Prestige
like it's you the knowledge is great and
training to learn more is awesome but
it's you and your self-confidence and
your willingness to help that's going to
help you close the sales
awesome man thanks Evan man I appreciate
it man cool man good luck Carlos thanks
for sharing man and thanks for coming
back it's great
all right we got uh Mina in the house
let's go Mina what do we got
it's the first time I speak let's go
Mina this is great yes
so I wanted to talk about my podcast I
do
um
uh two episode one short uh on Tuesday
less than five minutes just to talk
about the topic and what will be next as
an interview and on Friday a publish an
interview okay so I prepare intro and
outro separately and when I add it to
the interview
I noticed the difference in voice
because
I do the interview on zoom and I prepare
on the intro and outro on my phone so uh
it's not the easiest thing to do is do
it on Zoom after they leave
I do right like I don't do an intro for
videos but at the end of every video
we'll throw at another video so if I do
an interview with Matthew McConaughey
who are we going to send to next well
who else have I had on my channel maybe
I'm going to send them to Les Brown I
remember going to send them to Tony
Robbins right
um
so I want to film that in the same
setting so Matthew comes on we talked
for 40 minutes cool he leaves I'm still
recording
and then I say hey if you want to see my
one-on-one with Tony Robbins check the
video right there next to me right so
you can keep it rolling
they leave
and then you do your whatever else you
need to record in that setting it's a
good idea it's the easiest yeah it's the
easiest way you're already in the same
setting same clothes same hair I know
the hair takes a long time you know it's
like you're already in the same Vibe so
it's easier just to continue going
yes because I want to
um transfer it on YouTube later
and the question is I have to ask
permission from my guests to do it on
YouTube or I can't do it without asking
them
uh so I've never really been one to to
get bogged down and in legal and
accounting uh not accounting but legal
issues some people
love that stuff
um what's the worst that happens the
worst that happens is they ask you to
take it down or they don't even contact
you and there's like a takedown notice
right that's the worst that happens
um I've never had that happen and I've
never
asked for permission either but it's
it's like not in the afterwards it's in
a setup so when they come on live like
what are they coming on to do
so they're coming on because it's it's a
show that's going to go on YouTube so
you set that up in in advance but
a lawyer would be strangling me right
now you know like of course you have to
have a signed waiver every time anybody
but like what's the worst case that
happens they take down the video right
which which has never happened to me so
it probably won't happen to you I don't
want to I'm not giving legal advice
I don't play a lawyer on TV
um but you can if you wanted to have a
simple waiver you could but the idea is
if they're doing a coaching session with
you then they know in advance like if
Carlos is doing an IG live they're
coming on IG and it's public so they
know it's public if you're doing a
coaching session like if Carlos were
then to take Carlos Sanchez's coaching
practice somebody's coming on that they
think is a private session and they're
talking about the childhood trauma and
then Carlos records it and posts it to
YouTube that's going to be a problem
right like he didn't the guest doesn't
know that that's going to be a video so
that's not even like a good ethical
thing to do whether it's legal or not
they take it down
um so it's just in the setup
it's just in the setup
letting them know that this is being
recorded and that's the exchange if it's
free it's because it's being recorded if
it's paid then it stays private yeah the
other question is I launched August 9
and she did it how can I Market my
podcast I post on Facebook and Instagram
the terminal of each
interview for example but I don't know
how to make it now so as to have more
listener and attract my audience is it
is it is it just in like an audio
podcast you have a video for YouTube too
it's audio for now it's audio it's Audio
Only it's Audio Only but I record all
the interviews that I want to make them
on YouTube
Okay the reason why I ask is when you go
video places like YouTube Instagram Tick
Tock I I focus on actually YouTube and
Tick Tock they have built-in
distribution so they can help you get
exposure if you have good content so the
in looking at Jose's Channel if he fixes
his thumbnails if he changes his titles
if you make some longer videos YouTube
will start to help promote those videos
on their own okay so if you want Audio
Only podcast
it's super difficult to have the
distribution built in so you have to do
a lot more of the marketing and
promotion of it right so yeah it doesn't
mean that you don't do any promotion
like if you're thinking how do I promote
the show cool well think about all
whatever you've got for yourself so it's
in the link of all of your social media
handles you create a newsletter where
you're talking about updates like Sandra
here helps me do my newsletter and uh
yesterday we sent out an email to two of
the videos that we launched on the
channel right so have a newsletter where
you're promoting the the videos
change the signature on your email so
every email you sent out has a link to
your Channel or has a link to your
latest interview where even if your your
emailing uh yelling on my team about
movement makers it's still in the PS
here's the latest video maybe she checks
it out right you're having all these
communications even if they're personal
ones you're sending something to your
best friend from high school but then in
the PS There's the link to your latest
podcast oh you have a podcast I didn't
know that like a lot of stuff happens
just in the communication yeah I sent it
but they did not click well that's fine
not everybody's gonna click like
especially in a PS they're not all gonna
click but it's there and wherever you
are creating you want to be like every
every social media account you have
there's a link that you have an option
to include so you want to put your links
there so like whatever whatever you can
do yourself you start building up your
audience and start people start to know
about it and as you start building a
bigger brand you'll have more people on
your email list you'll have more people
follow you on Instagram right and so
more people will start to see it with
time
so whatever you own yourself the second
thing is your guests or your guests
willing to promote it or your guests
willing to share it are your guests
willing to put it into their email list
or on their social media can you cut out
their best quotes or best clips and give
it to them so they can share it as well
like the more you can make it easy on
your guests to share
the better yes I give them the Trump
nail and they post the template or
Instagram and Facebook they share with
their audience here and there's an
actual video clip or just a picture just
a picture and the link to listen to the
podcast cool so one of the best things
you can do is what we do every day
pretty much is on Instagram stories
we'll cut the best Clips so we made a
list of our 100 interviews that I've
done with people
podcast style right
and we've pulled out our favorite clips
from those videos
we'll put it to our Instagram story of a
video clip and tag them
yeah so then it's a one-click share for
them so I don't know who we did today if
you look at my Instagram stories you'll
see who we've done you know today
and then we tag them in it
and then one then maybe they don't see
it okay but two maybe they do see it and
if they do see it then they know oh yeah
Mina that was a good conversation and
then three maybe they share it because
all they have to do is Click add to
their story now it's being sent out the
key thing with it is though it's ongoing
like
the the Matthew McConaughey I
interviewed him I don't know last year
but still once a month I'm taking a clip
I'm posting it to my channel again most
people are so worried about the latest
episode and they don't do enough of the
archive content
so I would take
you know however many interviews are
done you know once you get to 30
interviews
then
you know if you interviewed Jose say
Jose comes on your channel you're going
to interview him cool then the seventh
of every month is Jose day
Jose day I like that so the seventh of
every month is Jose day right and what
you do is you take a clip and you post
it to your story something that makes
Jose look good Jose says something
awesome you take a 15 second clip post
it to your Instagram story and you tag
Jose on the 7th of every month
not just when it launches but every
month becomes Jose day on the 7th and
then every month Jose is going to get a
notification that you tagged him because
that goes to your that goes to his
direct messages that you tagged him in a
story he's going to see that you're
still sharing him so now he's thinking
about you again and he can One Click
Share it to his audience so it's like
Tony Robbins shared to his audience
Deepak Chopra shared to his audience
like for the people I've interviewed
even though it's like a year or two
after I've interviewed them
and then what you slowly start to do is
as you interview people with bigger
followings you take out some of the
people so you know if the third of every
month was Susan day but Susan doesn't
really have a big following as you get
more and more people maybe the third
becomes lady Lexi day and not Susan day
anymore right and you start
right so most people focus only on the
launch
cool
but what you want to do is promote it
Evergreen so you have your 30 days of
the month and one day goes to each
person and as you get more than 30
people you start subbing some people in
and out based off who has the bigger
following at least on Instagram you tag
them and it's so super easy for them to
share
Abraham yeah Jay Abraham so Abraham I
interviewed I don't know how old that is
it's like at least two years old
and on my story today is a Jay Abraham
clip and he saw and somebody on his team
messaged me today and my Instagram said
thank you for sharing
and maybe he shares at his audience I
don't know we'll see but it's like two
years ago and and the 15th you know is
still Jay Abraham
yeah Peter says for me every Sunday's
Evan's clip with animation yeah and if
you tag me and I like it and I see it
I'll probably share it now Peter's
hacking my audience
so that's the way to do it and
congratulations thank you so much thank
you so much Evan I love it thank you
guys
how to create a framework to teach
something ooh that's a good one I like
that we actually start that with inside
build to serve page 152 153 recipe for
success I know you guys all have the
book because you're in this group
uh there's a three-step process that
that I guide people through for you to
figure out what helped you have success
that is the thing that then you can
teach other people
so you've tried a million things right
whatever whatever hole you're in
whatever pain you came from you tried so
many things to get out I remember with
my first business I tried so many
different things so many different
things and I felt like nothing was
working like just everything I tried
just nothing was working uh and then I
discovered mall and success right then I
discovered hey Bill Gates started
Microsoft how can I model his success
and that one thing became then the thing
that I've done for the past 21 years
it's crazy 21 years so
that strategy of Mullen success is the
thing that saved me and now it's what I
teach other people it's why I make my
YouTube channel that's why I have the
you know posters on the wall here behind
me everything that I've done for the
past 20 plus years whenever I don't know
what to do model success that was what
saved me but I tried a lot of other
things that didn't work as well
so out of all the million things that
you try to get out of the hole you found
one two three things that actually
worked
that's what you have to remember you
have to go back in time to when you are
really really struggling how did you get
out of that hole and and write down the
steps right so page 153 your recipe for
Success number one is when did you
decide that something had to change so
step one to actually help people change
is realize they have to decide to change
right you can give them if we're talking
about teaching
we as teachers love teaching we love
giving information we love giving it
knowledge we love giving the the
information we want people to change
right but if they're not if they haven't
decided to change yet then none of your
strategies are going to matter you could
tell them you know what they need to do
but they're not going to listen to you
they're not actually going to implement
if they have not decided that they need
to make that actual change right now
uh you know Evan Ten's been in the group
I know struggled with alcohol addiction
for a long time and
he could have easily been given the
strategies he probably was given the
strategies a bunch of times by different
people he could have easily gone to
books or or articles and found hey
here's how to deal with it but he wasn't
ready yet
you know he wasn't ready at the
beginning to deal with it he hasn't
decided to change so the strategies that
you're giving don't matter yet until the
person is ready to change so go back to
your own story what was the moment that
you decided that you had to change for
me it was quitting on my business
partner right I was saying I quit I I
hate this I I need to I need to feel
like I'm a valuable human being I'm
working my face off I'm getting zero
results this can't keep going like this
that's when I decided that something had
to change so go back to your story when
did you decide that something had to
change and then you need to pull that
out of people so in your sharing of your
story you have to make it
uh be relatable which it will be right
because it's your own personal story you
have to not just gloss over it and just
tell the surface level version of it you
got to take me deep into how you were
feeling and what actually sparked the
change
and that gets people mentally prepared
to then actually listen to the teachings
right so I need it's why your story is
so important even though it's it's scary
to share uh and and you might be word of
judgment or criticism uh if people don't
know what you went through they're not
going to listen to your advice because
they're going to say well he well she's
not like me he doesn't get me right so
you have to tell your story and you have
to go back to that point in your story
when you decided that you had the change
you were wrestling with this for for
months or years or decades or some
people
and it's this moment that you decided
that you had to change that's step one
then two was what was the first thing
you did to start to change right so
three steps right what was the first
thing you did to start the change it may
seem insignificant it may seem small it
may not seem like a big deal but what
was the first thing you did so for me it
was
I just asked myself somebody else has
had to build a software company before
and had success like who was it who was
it and and the only person I could think
of was Bill Gates and it didn't seem
like it was this groundbreaking strategy
didn't seem like this was going to be
the thing that I was going to spend the
next 21 years doing right it just didn't
seem it was that big but it actually
turned out to be and so that first step
is super important because a lot of
people if you just give the big strategy
for where they could go you tell them
where they could be in five years or ten
years or even next year they won't
believe you
they don't think it's possible they
don't think it's it's they have an
ability to get to that next big step so
what was the first little step that you
took that that in the moment felt
insignificant and small but actually
made a big difference so that gives
people hope that gives people courage
that makes me feel like it's possible so
what was the first thing you did to
start uh the change and then how did you
sustain the momentum was number three so
how did you sustain the momentum because
you you tried and stopped a bunch of
things
so how did you actually keep that thing
going what were the what were the the
strategies the tactics the habits like
what did you do to now suddenly be able
to stay consistent where in the past you
weren't
and inside of those three questions is
the framework to teach
all we want to really do is help them
get to where we are right now right you
say look at look at everything that's
possible look at where I've come you can
do this too that just don't believe that
it's possible for them
it's like to take people through that
three-step process inside those layers
and it depends on your specific story
right what worked for me is going to be
totally different than what worked for
for Krista or Duong or D or Brian or
yunski or all you awesome people here in
the chat
but that three-step process becomes the
framework to teach
uh the next question was from Chris who
said how do you know when to keep
pushing forward and when to just move on
so the short answer is
you move on when you stop loving it
I think a lot of people
honestly even stay in businesses or stay
in relationships for too long and they
realize they stopped loving their
business a year ago or two years ago or
four years ago and they and they kept
going with it just because they didn't
want to look like a failure just because
they didn't want to tell their family
that they're closing or how their
friends would see them and they have to
start over or the humility to have to go
get a job but if you stop loving
something that's when you quit because
you're never going to win doing work
that you hate
you're just not you're never going to if
you're waking up today like oh I hate
doing if I woke up today it's like oh
inside for this readers group I hate
these guys
then then it's not gonna work I'm not
gonna have the energy I'm not gonna have
the passion I'm not gonna have great
answers and it's slowly going to eat
away at me now I love you guys this is
fantastic it's like this is the best way
to start for me uh but when you stop
loving it that's when you move on on the
flip side if you still love it and
you're not getting results then you have
to keep going
because why don't what ends up happening
is you're going to regret it if you love
doing this thing
but it's just not you know working out
yet you haven't hit the financial goals
you've got you haven't had the customer
goals you've got whatever metrics you've
set for yourself but it's not air quotes
working for you yet if you quit now
and then you go do something else
what's going to happen is you're going
to look back on this moment in three
months and six months and a year in 20
years and say I wish I kept going
because I loved it
so this is not something that anybody
can tell you to to to quit or not this
is a heart decision
so as long as you keep as long as you
still love doing the thing you might
have to find a different way to stand as
a Oprah Winfrey quote like I had to find
a different way to stand you can't keep
doing it the way that you've been doing
it you have to find some adjustments
it's not just keep photocopying the same
thing you have been doing because that
hasn't been working but you have to keep
going and find a different way to stand
instead of quitting because you will
regret that decision the rest of your
life so Ronald asked how to squeeze some
business time into a family day
so that's interesting especially on a
day like today which is a holiday for a
bunch of you guys here
um who are watching live
I do this a couple ways one I
actually integrate my my family my wife
my son into the business uh Nina's very
familiar with what I'm doing in the
company and I used to have a really hard
time when she had a nine-to-five job
and I would be working and when she came
home she wanted to talk about she wanted
to ask me questions about my day and
what I was doing and what happened today
and
I didn't I don't have I have no need to
actually talk about what what I'm doing
you know if I have a problem I solve the
problem not by talking about it but by
trying to fix the problem and so
it was it felt frustrating for me to
try to remember what happened today for
people to share it but I realized it was
really important to her
and when the people around you
understand what's going on in your
business
and how it affects you emotionally it
doesn't become as big a Hot Topic right
so if you're trying to find an hour
today on Thanksgiving or to be here
right some people are not here because
they're celebrating Thanksgiving right
which is totally cool but you're trying
to find a 25 minute window to be here
and say I'm gonna go hang out with Evan
Carmichael instead of you guys today
right now
for them to know what this means to you
like let's just use this live as an
example for them to know what this means
to you to your business to your life to
what you're trying to create to the
community that it's helped give you
right for them to know how important
this is for you
makes a big difference compared to oh
he's just off working again
he's just stopped doing that thing right
you've blocked them out from your life
and so now they're angry at the work and
they blame the work instead of seeing it
as that integration so when they know
how important it is to you when they
know exactly what you're doing and why
and what it means to you and that just
takes an extra level of communication
it's not like you're asking for
permission right this is where people
can get blocked you're not asking for
permission to come and be on this live
or do that call or watch that video or
whatever business time is going to be
for you you're not asking for permission
you're just helping bring them into your
world
whether they can be a part of your world
and actually help you do anything right
at the beginning Nina couldn't really
help me do anything in my business she
wasn't she didn't have a role so I
didn't I didn't
I didn't see the value in just
explaining what I was doing and I did
definitely didn't want to ask her for
permission for what I was doing but
in explaining it it brought her into my
world it created more understanding and
it made things a lot easier it allowed
her to get to know me better
so if you're trying to carve out time
for work on a on a holiday or family day
the family has to feel like you're not
choosing that thing over you that
there's not this big divide between you
and that comes by from explaining and
lending them into your world right now
going a level deeper is actually trying
to involve them somehow I had a guy on
my Instagram live who's part of my
movement makers program and he
is teaching fathers how to be better uh
how to teach fathers with daughters how
to be better fathers basically and he
wants to start this show interviewing
people and and talking about what it is
to be a father and he was trying to
carve out time for like I don't have a
lot of time because I have I have a job
until this thing takes off and I've got
I've got family responsibilities and so
I only have this amount of time you know
in the morning to be able to do this
I said well why not involve your
daughters in the show
why not have your daughters come in and
help you do the interviews when you're
when you're talking to some expert about
Parenthood why not have one of your
daughters ask a question as well
and any
took a pause and then said holy cow this
is a totally different way of seeing
things and so now it's not just okay
this is my work life and then you guys
are doing your own thing
maybe your family can be a part of what
you're doing and can be now more
emotionally involved with the work that
you're doing too and and maybe bring
even more joy and satisfaction to you
right so now he's doing he's got a I
think it was 11 and 13 year old daughter
and now they're researching who to who
to interview who they can bring on who
they can ask questions to and uh now now
his business isn't just this thing
isolated all on its own
that makes sense
uh okay
I found that you have to be nimble
because things change and evolved from
how you originally think is going to
happen how do you suggest shifting but
not losing the message how do you handle
your close relatives feelings on your
comments about yourself and sharing your
story that might implicate them okay so
so those are two different questions
um
let's go with the family one first
when you're sharing your story
I'm very careful not to throw anybody
under the bus
some people
obviously your family is involved in
what's happening
um some people have no problem with it
some people like no I hate that man
I don't care that the world knows that
it was him
and so they they're super happy to do it
um
I'm not in that camp you know I don't
like throwing somebody under the bus but
a lot of the story
you don't have to say who it is a lot of
the times when I'm sharing
um stories if I look at my espresso
videos where I'm going on rants or on
I'm stage speaking and I'm telling a
story about something happened to me
maybe it's Nina and and I know that
she's okay with it
uh but otherwise if it's someone in my
family I'll often just change the
relationship or I'll change the gender
or I'll say someone close to me because
it actually doesn't really matter that
it was your father
it doesn't really matter that it was
your aunt
all that matters is it was somebody
close to you who hurt you
I made you feel this way
right so you don't have to call them out
by name and make them feel bad what
matters is your side of it without
saying that they're a terrible person or
they're a terrible human being all that
matters that you felt this way because
of what happened
and so if you have to change some of the
circumstances you have to change the
gender
um you could definitely change the name
if you're going to even say a name
that doesn't really matter
um all that matters is how you felt
about it how you felt afterwards and
then what you did to get out of the hole
uh and then the other question was about
being Nimble be firm on the why and
flexible on the how right so the the why
doesn't change how you do it will change
a million times
you know I want to sell the world's
biggest problem I want to help
entrepreneurs believe in themselves I
want to help the world believe
themselves but specifically
entrepreneurs I want people to wake up
and feel like today they could do
something
bigger better Bolder than they did
yesterday that you've got Michael Jordan
level genie says something right that's
what I wake up every day trying to do
how I accomplish that's going to change
a million times you know it's why we it
built to serve we go through it right
The Who and the why are stable
they don't change once you figure out
your who your most important core value
and your why that that sets you up for
life when you're 120 years old you'll
still care about those two things but
the how how you accomplish it will
change I've had a pretty good run you
know on YouTube where it's been
11 years 11 and a half years April 2009
yeah so 11 and a half years on YouTube
we just crossed 400 million views which
is crazy
uh it's crazy
what's the population of the US it's
like something like that maybe it's more
now
um
anyway it's hard to it's hard to imagine
I never thought I'd be at you know 400
million views when I when I started this
thing not at all
um but
it'll change you know in 20 years it may
not be YouTube anymore right we're going
to be hosting these all in some kind of
virtual reality room uh or VR in into
some place or holograming you know we're
all gonna meet in Evan Evan tinsman's
office you know for the next event
that's it's going to change the
technology will change but
the why stays consistent so this is why
creating a perfect business plan is
never a great idea because you don't
have enough knowledge to actually know
right so many people I see spend so much
time building the perfect the perfect
business plan and then they get out to
Market and start executing it and it
doesn't work
because they didn't have the perfect
information because the best way to
actually test it is to go talk to people
go start selling go start marketing go
start creating you never know which
one's going to work until you actually
start doing it but you have to get up
every day and start doing it and so
YouTube's been awesome
um you know we're playing with Tick Tock
and we're on Instagram and doing other
other forms of content I'm always going
to be doing work to help entrepreneurs
but I'm not fixed on how it happens
um in the past 24 months I was asked to
do so much speaking
and and getting bigger stages and bigger
events and then covert hits and then the
speaking goes to zero there are no
events right there's no actual events
happening all the people who are
organizing events were struggling to
figure out what do we do now this is my
entire business
and so now they're doing online events
and you've probably seen a whole bunch
of them tons of different online events
summits I think even more online events
now than there were you know offline
events before covet uh and so they
adjusted I adjusted that's that's the
plan like look at what's happening right
now with covet I'm sure you've had to
make a whole bunch of adjustments
compared to your life before
but the why shouldn't change
and so it's being super stubborn on the
why
the vision that you're trying to create
and then flexible on the how of how
you're going to accomplish it forever
like it's always gonna it's always going
to be there's always going to be shock
to the system it's always gonna be the
next thing that whether it's external
like covered whether it's something that
happens close right a family member
passes away like you'll have these
shocks to your system that
push you backwards
and you have to make an adjustment but
just keep remembering the why and being
being stubborn on it
uh crystal says how do you move past
insecurities that your content is not
good enough
so the first step is recognizing that
you're insecure that your content's not
good enough and that's actually a big
first step for most people they find
really smart reasons why they can't do
it
I can't make a YouTube video because I
don't have the camera and I I don't have
the story to share and I don't have like
all these excuses why they can't start
and and I see Zen saying the man Smith
here in the house and
be all hands up uh and Zan joined me on
my on my YouTube gaming channel so I
stream League of Legends four times a
week and answer questions as we go and
he was talking about making content
and doing Instagram live to push him hey
you got to make an Instagram live he's
like okay yeah yeah I'll do that great
great okay like tonight like tonight I
don't even know how it works
like well I'll show you get your phone
press this button then press that button
and boom you're going live and uh Yuko
who's also here in the chat was his
first person who joined him live
uh and it was awesome I never after that
Zane went live the next day again with
somebody else and now he knows how to do
it
we we create these so the first step to
overcome the insecurity is recognizing
that you're actually insecure because
you know in his head Zen's got all these
ideas for I'm gonna I'll do that in
January or I've got this plan for
December and when he was talking about
his YouTube plan he's like yeah I'm
gonna launch those videos next year like
next year dude next year is like 20 40.
come on let's go where's that I want
that video by tomorrow
so we have these Perfect Plans and we
have all these reasons why we can't do
things
and really it's just masculine and
insecurity so the the biggest first step
is just recognizing that you are
insecure about it and that's fine and
that's normal and that's human and
that's actually great because
people who are watching you don't want
to learn from the perfect person they
want to learn from somebody who is kind
of like them if you come across as
perfect all the time then to say well
that person's just perfect they don't
get me they don't understand what I what
I'm going through they're not like me so
I can't I can't learn from them so step
one recognize that you are insecure
awesome step two you then need to tell
yourself that being insecure is not a
good enough reason
to stop accepting the fear accepting the
insecurity as a good enough reason for
you not to take action
so anytime I I use it a couple ways so
scary difficult or hard right when I say
those words it means I have to do it or
the boom boom boom test which is when my
heart's beating like this that means I
have to do it just because even if it
doesn't work out like expect it to suck
expect your first videos to suck expect
it not to go well like Zan's first live
he's like what am I doing here this is
working uh Evan are you there you know
it's like
and listen it was mine too like whatever
how does this work oh I'm live oh great
wow okay awesome yeah you don't I just
expect it to suck why do you expect it
to be great the first time out right
expect the thing to suck the problem is
we take that content sucking and we we
wear it as we suck
Zane the man doesn't suck as a human
because his first Instagram live wasn't
fantastic at the beginning right just
because it sucked it doesn't mean that
you suck
so I just expected to suck and and as a
I flip it to say I'm amazing that I did
that I'm amazing that I tried that was
scary oh my God I'm awesome because if
you keep stepping up and doing the scary
things that you're insecure about it's
gonna get better right if if Zan makes
100 Instagram lives and we compare 100
to the first one it's gonna be a world
of difference
and and you can go back and watch my
video somebody posted on Instagram
uh this morning one of my first videos
and say like wow I can't believe this is
Evan like yeah you can go back and watch
go back 11 years ago and watch all the
content that was there uh there's been a
lot of growth and development and and
it's been definitely quite the journey
but
I kept all those videos up so you can
you can watch the progression and
hopefully it doesn't have to take you 11
years to get here you know as well but
just recognize that you are insecure to
except being insecure isn't a good
enough reason for you to act
um and then three just expect to suck at
the start you know to your point I think
was Crystal and I know I know we're a
time already it's crazy holy cow
um it took me 350 videos until I wasn't
completely embarrassed by my content and
I think I I think I share that story and
built a survey but 350 videos 350 public
videos where I couldn't watch it back
I would play like oh stop it just post
it on YouTube and that next I could not
watch it back
um and then 700 videos before I inspired
myself where I watched my video back and
like oh you know what I'm that's
starting to get pretty good you know I
like that little video there that's
pretty good I'm I'm on to something
700 videos later right I mean crazy
amounts of content
um so I I was really slow and really bad
um the only difference I just kept going
and I think I think all of you here
could probably get there way faster than
me
the problem is just allowing those
insecurities to stop you so you do
difficult things you do scary you do
difficult you do hard you're not going
to let those things slow you back
because they're going to continue to
show up if you let your insecurities win
today they're going to win tomorrow
they're going to win the next day and
win the next day as well and and what's
your message to your audience is your
message
only do something when it's perfect
you know probably not I hope not
right so but you're living it right your
message isn't only do something when
it's perfect but in your message to
yourself is I'm not going to release
until it's perfect right so you have to
start actually living and bringing the
audience in let them know I'm actually
really nervous doing this right if
that's how you feel let them in tell
them you're nervous and show them that
you still show up when you're nervous
um so super important and whether that's
writing a book making YouTube videos
Instagrams going live any of that stuff
it all all relates I know we're over but
super quick story about Yuko when she
came in she she came to my dance studio
here in Toronto and she brought these
awesome butter tights oh my God if you
guys know what butter tarts are imagine
a pecan pie
but the size of a tart with no pecans on
it that's a that's basically a butter
type it's a Canadian thing
um and she also made this green tea
butter tarts which were amazing uh and
and she was afraid to to make videos
make content I said you know what on on
your way home she was gonna go to this
really busy train station uh Union
Station here in Toronto and I said you
have to go make a video there and find
somebody and make a video in Union
Station
um it's like oh my God I can't do that
I've barely even made any videos how are
you gonna go do that
and then but then she did it she did it
she went and she found a woman who liked
her backpack or something I forget what
the exact story was but she did it and
she filmed it and she was on and the
woman was on and and then after was like
oh my God I can't believe I just did
that it's crazy it's something I would
never do right and she did it and and
that's what you want to teach yourself
that when you come up against the fear
barrier that you do the thing right
don't do something stupid don't don't
like jump in front of a train because
that's a scary thing to do right okay
that's just a stupid thing to do but
especially when the fear is other
people's judgments of like who's
watching me with my camera here in this
busy train station it's not a good
enough reason not anymore for you not to
take action if you want to get a copy of
build to serve and join us live for our
next training with me to ask your
questions you can go get the book right
there next to me right there I'll see
you there I'll see you to get the book
it's a good one much love